oh right we are not all live and I'm up
here in the bedroom you can see the
bookshelves behind me just lighting a
little bit you one of the features I'd
love if YouTube would actually bring
back is they're adjusting lighting and
stuff like that and if they could adjust
sound that would be really amazing
you know this feature seems to be
working properly for once which is good
we already have a lot of people here and
a lot of questions lined up I'll just
say this I wanted to do a stream that
would be sort of a end to the the decade
I know some people are you know
sticklers
oh no the decade doesn't end until you
know some other point but as far as
everybody else is concerned this is the
end of the 2010 and for me as I pointed
out in the video that I did just
yesterday that has been in large part a
decade for me to be on on YouTube and a
decade of moves move first up to New
York to be with Andy Shaka my my wife
from Fayetteville North Carolina and
then we moved from Kingston New York
back here to Milwaukee where we
currently live and I imagine we will
probably stay as home base the rest of
our life and when we do want to travel
eventually once we're no longer quite so
busy and our finances are in great shape
which is you know something we're
committed to this decade but for now
we're really happy to be here so I see
that one person asked about New Year's
resolutions and another person said no
New Year's resolutions I haven't
actually like formalized New Year's
resolutions at this point what I did was
when I when I hit my 80 my August 18
that's why I'm saying 18th when I hit my
49th birthday back in August I came up
with a list of things that I wanted
to be in in better condition or better
shape by the time that I hit 50 so you
know things I was gonna work out one is
you know getting to the gym regularly
this 7 class semester really took a toll
on that because I was spending so much
time either doing class prep or grading
or going to or from classes or dealing
with student issues or actually teaching
there were all sorts of technology
problems with the prison class that I
was teaching that sucked up a lot of
time and energy so I you know my goal is
to to get to the gym five days a week in
this coming year and I'm figuring you
know I'm by the way I'm not looking for
advice about what sort of workouts to do
I've got that that quite covered you
know I like my weight circuit which I'll
be doing three days a week my cardio
circuit which I'll be doing two days a
week I've got a you know elliptical
downstairs in our little gym for our
apartment complex like I can always use
if I want to I'm gonna start walking a
lot more around here just for a pleasure
part of that was just not having enough
time so you know there's all of that
coming up obviously I want to get a lot
more reading time in that's that's quite
important for me I get some more
academic writing done and get to get
some book projects actually if not
published under way at least and you
know as always work on my relationship
with with my wife and II and with other
people involved in my life like you know
my kids who are kind of a moving target
since their adolescence so I don't I
don't actually have any you know like
actionable New Year's resolutions at
this point and I'd be interested to see
how other people in the chat you know if
you want to put way your New Year's
resolutions are I think that would be
kind of kind of cool so let me there's
already a lot of questions here let me
address those Daniel Williams asks about
a Daniel Russell book called practical
intelligence and the virtues
I've never read it so I can't really say
much about it but then he asked you
think Aristotle's idea of phronesis or
practical intelligence is relevant in
our times and I would say yeah but I'm
coming more and more to see that much in
Aristotle that's that's important is
really underdetermined and Aristotle
will often make rather sweeping
statements that have to be qualified
from an Aristotelian perspective and I
think too many Aristotelian 's take some
of the statements that he makes at their
you know at his word and then try to
cobble together a system out of it and I
don't think that's very resilient
actually so you know I've always been a
big admirer of Alistair McIntyre and
other new Aristotelian is doing doing
similar work where they say well we have
to adapt Aristotle we have to rethink
Aristotle along those lines and taking
into account what other traditions for
example the stoic tradition a you know a
long has a great argument in one of his
pieces about this that the stoic
tradition is actually a MacIntyre II and
tradition constituted rationality it has
to take into account what its rivals
would have to say so
yeah phronesis is absolutely important
how we conceptualize it I don't think
Aristotle provides us with sufficient
resources for the conceptualization of
it in the texts that we have so we need
to go to look at later Aristotelian 's
the commentator tradition and and by
that I don't mean jumping straight ahead
to Thomas Aquinas I mean reading
Alexander of Aphrodisias and I mean also
looking at what other non non not
specifically Aristotelian but certainly
taking Aristotle into account thinkers
like like Cicero or Plutarch would have
to say about it as well so Jakob or
Jakob Donato meta philosophy Vidkun
Stein philosophy is one and all
extension is only humanities personality
and the answer of explanation is as
simple as it's been a dolt behaving
badly I don't know what any of that
means but it sounds kind of interesting
so I'll take you at your word
Camille asked maybe it's time to
summarize philosophy in the 21st century
where is it going I don't know that's
that's a good question if we're talking
about academic philosophy that and that
extends not just to who's teaching but
also like who's publishing in
traditional philosophy journals and
presses like Oxford at you know
University across or you know Stanford
University Press or things like that I
think philosophy is at this point so
fragmented that any attempt to try to
provide some sort of definition that
would Corral everybody in is doomed to
failure or to stifling you know
philosophical work and innovation I
don't know where philosophy said it I
guess you could say that doing
philosophy and popular ways is going to
be massively important one thing I would
say is that if we look at the history of
not just philosophy but the history of
ideas generally one thing that we can
say for certain is that whatever people
were taking to be the most important
thinkers and ideas of their time they're
usually wrong and the format's in which
people think philosophy or whatever
counts as philosophy has to be done in
their time are usually passed up and
played around with you know and you
don't have to be a post modernist to buy
into that I think you just have to like
you know actually look at history and
approach it in a non schematic way so I
don't know where things are going
oh Calypso going to be finishing my
first read of
gorgeous tonight might follow it up with
starting Aristotle's rhetoric on New
Year's Day that's that's good the
gorgeous is quite important for you
might say setting the stage and allowing
yourself a contrast between Plato's
rather dismal conception of rhetoric I
mean there is that like possibility of
good rhetoric and the Phaedrus and then
Aristotle's much more pragmatic
conception of the importance of rhetoric
as being something related to dialectic
and necessary and ethics and teaching
and politics and all these these other
air and having connections with with
literary composition in the poetics so
that's yeah that's a good thing to do
our tea would be what did Plato Socrates
and Aristotle think about the
relationship between knowledge and
virtue they thought knowledge was
important for virtue Socrates and Plato
appeared to thought that the virtues are
types of knowledge Aristotle thinks that
it that they are as well to some degree
but you know Aristotle differentiates
between a lot of different types of
knowledge you know just read nikka mckay
and ethics book six and you'll see that
so you know there's some connection
between the two
obviously simply knowing things isn't
enough or actually having virtue or or
doing things andrew says hi Greg thanks
for doing this you you're very welcome
earlier I was listening to a podcast
that attacked stoicism as pessimistic in
nature what would be a good defense
against this telling them to actually
read the texts stoicism the gloss on
stoicism is that it's pessimistic in
nature simply reading stoic thinkers
would disabuse one of that very quickly
and people who don't actually read the
texts I'm not sure what you can do with
them other than telling them hate the
actual writings say something that
contradicts your
mistaken view on things so
you know that's that's kind of a hard
one factotum you got a question here on
Blind Guardian so I haven't listened to
for years
so I can't really say much about it
Blind Guardian and their song about the
Iliad and the album about Tolkien's
nightfall in middle-earth I don't really
know those you know I don't I don't
really listen to a lot of post-90s metal
they are they are a good as far as I
remember I had a good power metal band
but I mean I'm I'm still rediscovering
stuff that was done in the 70s and 80s
and sometimes early 90s that that's
fairly mind-blowing and so I I'm not I'm
not I don't really have much expertise
when it comes to the later power metal
bands I actually the later any job I
don't I don't have that much to say even
about doom metal Aaron asks any thoughts
on dr. Peterson's work talked about that
many times I don't hold it in any you
know high respect I think that his first
book is just kind of gobbledygook
mishmash of all sorts of things with a
lot of diagrams thrown in you know I
don't think that he ever made his
reputation on the basis of that that
book maps of meaning I think it was the
the videos that people had of him and
you know I like some of the same
thinkers that it does like Dostoevsky
and Nietzsche and social Neeson but I
certainly don't come to the same
conclusions that he does and I think
that he's a careless scholar you know
his view on what what post-modernism is
is clearly inadequate and highly
polemical he showed up to his discussion
with with jejak without having done
basic research into you know what
communism would be other than reading
the communist manifesto so you know he's
the kind of person who if if he was a
peer I probably like many of his own
peers in his university would tena
ignore I guess he appeals to a lot of
young men but it's sort of like a diet
any diet you go on you're probably gonna
lose some weight at the start so you
know if you use his rules for life
you're bound to like fix some things in
your life but why not
why not go with something better why go
with something that's got so many
ideological commitments unless it's
really that you love those ideological
commitments like you're an anti-feminist
you know or you you think that you know
it really is a matter of order versus
chaos but then [ __ ] why not why not just
read like Roger Zelazny or Michael
Moorcock or some of the great you know
fantasy writers who are talking about
that why do I buy into this guy stuff so
arty Whitby did Plato think some types
of knowledge are more valuable than
others
depends on what you call knowledge so if
you look at the divided line in republic
book book six and then you followed up
with the allegory of the cave and book
seven there are some things that are
clearly knowledge their knowledge in a
broad sense and they have to do to the
forms but it's the way in which the
forms are apprehended are they
apprehended by way of like abstracting
from material things or they understood
in their own light or you're grasping
the form of the good so yeah of course
those are some of those are better than
others but they're all great it's sort
of like saying you know which do you
like better the oysters the filet mignon
you know well they're both better than
oatmeal you know and then you know a lot
of thetaf sets the bar for what consoles
knowledge so high this is where he and
Aristotle are quite different that most
things that we would consider knowledge
aren't really knowledge in his in his
book right so it's it's kind of a
non-starter until we get to later
commentators on the plateless
all right
suave tasks the video isn't even up yet
why the hell are there already just
likes cuz there's dicks out there
there's our people who you know like to
have a beef about something I'm always
amazed you know with some of the videos
that I post it seems like no matter what
philosopher you pick there's somebody
who doesn't like what you're doing with
it and I also do a little rant here
there's always people who are like you
know the core concept videos where those
would be really great if you just get
rid of that long intro and my answer to
them is always like I'm actually gonna
shoot one of those dr. Sandler responds
videos are you are you so like entitled
them and lazy that you can't like skip
ahead you know 30 seconds 45 seconds if
that really really bothers you you're
getting you know sort of an expert
discussion might not be the best expert
discussion but an expert discussion of
stuff for free and you're gonna complain
about it but you know that's that's the
nature of the world that we live in and
and it's always been that way
you know going back to Plato right one
of the cool things about Plato even if
he's wrong about most things he's right
about this any instance of some sort of
ideal that you find in reality is always
going to be flawed and you can always
look at it from a different side and
find justice to be in justice in some
respect but it doesn't cease to be the
good that is the relative good that it
is because of that so alright let's
let's see what's going down here just
skipped again that's one of the features
I wish they'd they'd fix on this is that
as soon as you start scrolling down it
like jumps all over the place alright
Aaron says like to thank your app take
this opportunity thank you for your work
I enjoy listening to your lectures great
I'm glad that they are helpful for you
you might want to check out the podcast
the Sadler's lectures because what I've
been doing is taking my
a core concept videos and turning those
into downloadable and lectures doing
that in part because then I can give
them to my students to listen to so I've
got to get a lot of those done for the
coming classes but they're you know
they're nice for other people too
because then if you want to listen to
the stuff you don't have to have YouTube
running in the background right there
was something else I was gonna say oh
yeah one of the other things that
Minister doing with the sale there's
lectures I've done this with a few they
start taking the sound files of my old
like public talks and turning those into
podcast lectures as well but most those
take a while all right
Gustavo s have you read to Quincy's last
days of Immanuel Kant I haven't as a
matter of fact I don't think I've ever
read to Quincy and that sounds kind of
interesting I I suppose I should take a
look at that I'm gonna be teaching
contig and as I always to see it's like
I'd never get away from from can't
because I'm doing ethics class this year
um Jo asks any hints on your book
projects yeah so this year I am gonna be
working with a co-editor to take the the
some of the articles from stoicism today
and put them into an edited volume that
hopefully will be out by the next stoic
on we're gonna be doing that for the
modern stoicism organization so all the
funds from that will go to help fund
modern stoicism activities which include
stoic on the stoic context is stoic we
call all this cool stuff I'm working out
a book I'm you know I've got a lot of
different book projects going on and one
of them the ones I'm going to be working
on this year is on stoicism and anger
understanding and managing anger I'm
using the Stoics and I may be working on
that with a collaborator or I may be
working on that
things are a little bit up in the air
about that I do have a lot of other book
projects that I want to get get back
working on but that's a matter of like
scheduling the time and jealously
guarding it you know not letting other
things get in there and that's just been
tough to do this last year I mean I
taught 15 academic classes including
through the summer and teaching classes
for me is not what it is for some people
just can phone it in I build entire
class shells for that I you know I don't
know how many people I did tutorial or
philosophical counseling or consulting
sessions with and you know I gave
probably at least 20 public talks over
the last year as well so I've gotta find
ways to make sure I get the writing done
when I need to get it done I also
mentioned too I said I was gonna get to
some academic writing so I'm doing some
academic writing on my own taking stuff
that was conference papers or you know
things I wrote and submitted before even
a few orphaned pieces I've got to like
work those back up into what I consider
good enough shape and then send them out
but I'm also doing some co-writing as
well and this is something that I
particularly like doing as an academic
we don't do this enough in philosophy
and I think we should encourage more and
more of that so I'll be doing some some
more co-written papers this year as well
doesn't mean they'll get published this
year of course because the academic
publication sometimes takes a very long
time to get through all right
Floyd asks would I ever make a video
series on Emmanuel Levinas
yeah as a matter of fact he somebody had
been meaning to get to in part because
in the ethics classes that I teach one
of the sort of broad topics is egoism
versus altruism right and so egoism you
know you look at say Plato and and and
Glaucon and the ring of guy Jesus and
the discussion of it in in book two
or we talk about it in Iran
I'm gonna be doing some stuff on mocks
Turner fairly soon as well and then for
the altruism stuff you know I like
Albert Schweitzer and I'll do some
videos hopefully on him some core
concepts stuff and also some stuff on
I'm letting us because Latinos does
articulate a certain kind of altruism
I'll be it in terms of you know an
absolute duty that is is you know
flowing ultimately from from God and is
revealed in the face of the other so
I'll be doing some stuff on Lebanon so
I'm not really sure which ones I'll be
doing uh comrade Gabe what are my first
and foremost broad thoughts on to lose
so this many times I like to lose I
don't like the stuff he does with guitar
II quite as much you know like aunty
Oedipus I really like the logic a sense
I really like essays critical and
clinical so you know and I like the
history of philosophy stuff that he does
but you should always remember that when
you're reading to lose as with many
other hits you know people doing history
of philosophy you're getting more to
lose than the actual person that he's
writing about so you know I don't like
to lose he ends that much but I don't
really like Ian's all that much when it
comes to most of the contemporary
continental stuff like I don't like
Lebanon's because all the all the
webinar sins that I know they just
blather on and on and on about how in
doing theory is hypocrisy and the face
of the other and blah blah blah blah
blah and after a while that gets kind of
tiresome because really it stands in the
way of doing anything productive with
the philosophy and and if we have to get
you know condemned the history of
philosophy prior to us as being just a
whole bunch of abortive mistakes which
lemme nasus himself is not doing but
Lebanon's often do then it's it's not
worth reading for as far as I'm
concerned you know nah meanness who in
philosophy do you have the most fun
reading well that's a great question
I you know I think I've I've said this
before love chef stuff is really really
fun totally anti systematic but really
incisive understands the you know the
movements and philosophy of his time
always willing to like get in that that
little barb here and there and I think
his earlier works are more enjoyable
than you know later works like Athens
and Jerusalem are probably that's that's
his most read book but yeah let's see
hangover here's what are your thoughts
regarding the stoic notion towards
suicide
so the Stoics thought that suicide was
justified but that most people who
commit suicide do so for the wrong
reasons and therefore it's unjustified
it's kind of paradoxical isn't it
alright it's it's fine for the sage to
do it or the person who's doing so
rationally but it's not fine for
somebody just to do it out of despair so
you know if you think about famous stoic
suicides
you know Cato commits suicide for a
greater purpose Seneca does so as well
at the order of Nero because if he
hadn't his family would have suffered
they weren't they weren't saying well
just do it whenever you want to you know
all right
Mongoose MC Queen love hi dr. Sailor
love your work thanks for that do you
have any advice for young people living
in an increasingly nihilistic atheistic
materialistic world hard to find meaning
yeah so I do and part of it is you are
not alone and this is not a world that
is Morni allistic at this point in time
than it was 20 years ago
for
years ago a hundred years ago Nietzsche
was already you know trumpeting these
you know the advent of an entire century
of niall ISM back in the late 19th
century it's just a question of how it
manifests itself to us and it's very
easy to feel as if our times are ways
shittier than anybody else's
now speaking from sort of a material
materialist basis and just looking at
things in terms of buying power that
capacity to to move you know socially
and stuff like that for younger people
and by that I would mean Millennials and
and you know generations EEMA you know
kids my my kids age college students as
well things are objectively worse it's
tougher to find jobs there's more
competition you have less buying power
you have less capacity to accumulate
equity healthcare education all these
things cost more way way more than they
should and things have been screwed up
for such a long time in so many
different ways that you know often seems
like it's it's impossible to change the
system and the trajectory that we're on
that said the boomers are gonna die and
Generation X my generation is still
around and many of them seem quite
motivated just to work on things and to
try to come up with solutions that the
boomers have for a long time stood in
the way of weather just through inertia
or you know selfishness or their own
misguided stuff you know I mean you know
who shares the most fake news the
Boomers and you know we could go on and
on and on with that and things are not
you know the other thing to keep in mind
is we don't just have the United States
we have
world-system parts of which are really
horrific parts of which are you know
better I mean we might actually someday
take the lead of the other civilized
first world countries and by that I
don't mean that other countries aren't
civilized I'm just saying there's a
certain level of civilization where you
start to say one measure would be do we
provide adequate health care for our
citizens and in the United States the
answer is no and in most of the other
places the answer is yes and it won't be
great but it'll East be you know a
modicum of care some places are moving
away from that like Britain because of
the Tory seems to be moving away from
that so you know if you consider things
in that light yeah things are pretty
shitty but we also live in a time when
if you want to you know watch videos
discussing a manual Contin you want to
learn about Kahn not only can you get
context online you can watch all sorts
of people discussing it and you can
communicate with other people about it
and that that allows not just you know
learning in terms of education but also
learning from the situations of other
people as well so I would you know it is
gonna sound Pollyannish but I would I
would try to focus on the positive as
much as you can one of the good things
about say stoicism or also you know
properly understood Aristotelian ism or
existentialism is it does say okay the
system itself does matter but it's not
the totality the individual does count
for something and you can work on this
part right and you're probably not gonna
ever like make it perfect I'm certainly
not not close to perfect and in many
things them do work on anger because I
still lose my temper but you can work on
yourself and you can work on that that
penumbra of relationships around you and
you can decide which which way you want
your life to go and sometimes it's tough
you know I'm seeing my own kids struggle
with these sorts of things and you know
you want to like solve the problems for
them but of course you can't but it is
it is possible to change
who you are and then how the world
weighs upon you so alright um bullets in
assent why is the video quality so bad I
don't know I'm not a tech person I you
know I wouldn't complain about it and
look on the bright side that you
actually get to be in on the stream I
mean that's what you want to ask about
okay Julian Carlson how can one reorient
oneself and pursue new relationships
after a painful long-term relationship
that's a good that's a good one that
came up somebody was was was writing
about that and I thought I I would do
some writing about that myself in the
new year because that's that's a common
issue so oh I know it was in a help a
reporter out query somebody's doing an
article on it so part of what you have
to do when you're coming out of the long
term relationship is constantly remind
yourself that you have become accustomed
to something that is no longer the case
and is not going to be the case so your
instincts your responses your your
feelings they're all gonna your thought
patterns they're all gonna be kind of
off and sometimes they're still good and
sometimes you may have you know great
realizations but you you probably want
to keep that in mind and avoid making
any big new commitments you know rebound
relationships are usually a bit of a
mistake I've been in some myself none of
them actually made it through and it's
good sometimes just to take some time
apart and and you know figure out what's
going on with yourself you're getting
used to like being no longer in in a a
kind of connection you know sort of like
taking off a uniform that you've worn a
long time or a car
you know like let's say you were an
insect you're molting or an arachnid all
right it's all gonna feel weird to you
[Music]
so I before you pursue new relationships
you do want to orient yourself that's
that's a great way to put it
and reorienting yourself you know I
personally think that the the big things
that you want to try to do to reorient
yourself think about what your life
goals are what you know what what do you
intend in terms of your education or
career think about you know your your
own physical health and whether you're
working out enough whether you're
getting the exercise that you need
whether you're eating well whether
you're taking care of yourself easy to
let slide when you're feeling depressed
think about what you want to study what
you want to get out of things how you
want to change yourself over time maybe
learn a new language
something like that right and you know I
would also like I would think about the
nature of your relationships may it
might be worth if you've had a lot of
them doing kind of a retrospective and
thinking oh man have I been doing like
the same pattern that I've been dating
the same person over and over again
maybe I need to to change that so all
right our brain hurts a lot thanks for
that professor do you know any secular
non spiritual books or ways to prepare
for death I'm young and healthy just
want to be ready yeah I mean that's
that's where philosophical traditions I
think can be quite helpful the Stoics
that's one of the things that they do
there they call it the pray meditate co
mall or I'm the you know thinking ahead
about bad things that could happen and
one of those are about death you know
you think about well if I die what's
what's gonna be the outcome of that what
am i leaving behind do I have the
resources to die well or am I gonna die
you know crying about it or things like
that
I think the existentialist have a lot of
great contributions to make
somebody who you wouldn't think about in
that light because when we say
existentialist people think like
Kierkegaard nietzsche okay there's that
and then then we got you know Heidegger
being towards death and jean-paul Sartre
and all that but I would actually
suggest taking a look at Rainer Maria
Rilke I would look at his letters to a
young poet and I would look at his I'm
not sure if I'm pronouncing it right do
we know allergies which are talking
quite a bit about death and I would read
around in his other letters too he wrote
quite a lot about that also you know
some good discussion of it in the
notebooks of malte laurits brigham his
is one main novel that he wrote there's
other you know good discussions about
the meaning of one's death in somebody
like Camus well and I don't mean just
the the you know the myth of Sisyphus
the rebel letter strim and friend those
those discussed that as well you know
his his his books his novels I mean not
and the stranger is okay but it's very
early novel and and it's kind of flat in
many respects compared to the plague or
the fall I would take a look at some of
those and then you know there's there's
a lot of really great discussions about
the meaning of death within the scope of
the character's life and thoughts by
speculative fiction writers philip k
dick is is pretty good in that respect
somebody who I read a lot of recently
that I really enjoyed was our Scott
Bakker but I don't know that he would be
that helpful
though he might Ursula kala green really
great philosophical science fiction and
fantasy writer so you know there's those
those sort of things that you can you
can look at as well
and you know another thing I would
suggest if it's if it exists nearby
there are these things that are called
death cafes and they're fairly
unstructured people get together and
they just talk about death in an
unstructured way for I usually like an
hour together over coffee and I mean the
mere fact that you can actually like go
there and talk with people that's a big
thing because most of the time people
want to avoid talking about death so you
know I think that that might be helpful
for you all right uh jail favorite
Lovecraft work that's tough
there are so many really good short
stories in his his stuff
and he's he's a great storyteller too I
know some people don't like him because
they think his stuff is too drawn-out
and he you know he has too many
adjectives in there but I don't know
that's I I have to take a pass on that
Artie Whitby since your scholar of
Aristotle and st. Anselm what are the
most common misconceptions about
Aristotle and Anselm of Canterbury
Anselm of Canterbury is easy that ollie
all he really did was the ontological
argument and you don't need to read any
further than chapter two perhaps to four
and Proust loggia or that he had a
feudal conception of the atonement and
that we've you know gone way past that
incurred Deus homo I mean that that's an
easy one right there Aristotle you know
the biggest misconception is that
Aristotle was an Aristotelian
Aristotelian are usually not as
interesting as Aristotle himself who's
got a much more fluid approach to things
most of the time he doesn't argue in the
in syllogisms the way that that people
would like to make him do so that's
probably good for that Wendy's got a
question that I'm not
to answer which Middle Eastern
philosophy do I think was the best
I don't read Arabic or Persian or any of
that that you know those those languages
so I can't read things in the original
and I haven't read you know widely in
Islamic philosophy so I'm not really a
good person to to say anything about
that
Jim Stampede since I posted a video
about my work in YouTube what do I think
about channels such as philosophy tuber
contra points
I feel like philosophy on YouTube was
getting too cinematic well I don't hold
them in high high regard I think they're
doing something very different than what
I'm doing which is to provide you know
sort of a even balanced competent
exposition of the ideas that I'm
discussing I think they are going for
being much more cinematic
and I was you know I was for example I
don't remember which I think it was
philosophy to very deeply disappointed
to see that you know he was essentially
reducing Hegel to the master-slave
dialectic you know you look at Hegel's
phenomenology the master-slave dialectic
is a tiny little sliver in it and then
there's all this other stuff in there
dealing with that stuff but in much more
complicated ways because the dialectic
of recognition on their Kennan which is
running throughout the entire work and
motivating the entire work is getting
you know worked out in much more complex
and developed ways so I think there's
there's a tendency to like go for the
very very low hanging fruits and to try
to get as many views as possible and to
make a buck
and you know get some notoriety but I
guess you got to ask what's what's gonna
be around to me that that video stuff is
still around you know a couple hundred
years from now what's gonna have made
any sort of lasting impact
glitzy stuff high production stuff that
you know essentially regurgitates the
same ideas as all the other things out
there or
or things that are going deeper into it
and again I'm not claiming that I'm
going to too deep into it I'm still
doing things at a fairly surface level
but that's because there's so much that
needs to be done all right
dominus is it a good or bad idea to read
philosophical chronologically neither I
mean you can you can read philosophy in
any way you want I'll say the same thing
that I say every time whatever order
you're gonna do it in you're gonna
deviate from that order because you're
gonna go back and reread stuff and it'll
be like sometimes reading it for a first
time after you've read some stuff later
on or you've read some things that
connect with it or you just developed a
better grasp of how to read
philosophical texts so as you know you
don't have to read things
chronologically I certainly didn't when
I was starting out but then again I
didn't have any guidance whatsoever from
my professors
John SIF stiff stiff derp yes stiff derp
has a very interesting suggestion here I
think the philosophy of personhood and
memory will be front and center in the
next decade due to genetic editing and
AI yeah I I think that that's probably
right and I don't know that it'll be
well genetic editing I guess will be a
part of that but you know what we call
neuroscience is sort of a just a grab
bag of stuff that's brilliant all the
way to stuff that's that's wrong and and
you know [ __ ] and everything in
between but that's that's become a
fixture of our scientific mentality and
that's gonna be playing an important
role and so that ties in with the
conception of personhood and agency and
all these other things that we think
about in terms of persons AI is
definitely going to play a role other
things that are going to come up with it
will be you know issues of the
robots and AI is that we use everything
from autonomous vehicles and they are
met thinking so much about cars but like
you know trucks and other other major
transportation things for all the goods
that we have all the way to sex robots
to maybe there'll be something like you
know back in the day there was Eliza
which was a it wasn't really an AI
program and it wasn't really a therapist
but it was it was it was purporting to
be something like that it was an early
basic program that you could write I
learned it when I was like 10 and there
will be something you know like that
eventually where you'll go and talk to
every you know William Gibson actually I
think has it in one of his books but
dick also has it some of his but I
Gibson I think he actually uses the word
Eliza eventually that'll be part of it
too and is that is that a person that
you're corresponding with or not you
know all of those are gonna come up as
well
spa bed has a medic question dr. Sadler
on these hangouts do you prefer rather
general questions or questions directly
related to philosophy or philosophers
either's fine you know sure if you mean
determinism in terms of like a
commitment to their being like a hard
determinism everything being determined
it's not just attention there's a
contradiction with Sartre existentialism
and Sartre discusses this very
extensively in being in nothingness so
you you would want to you know dig
around and there it comes up a lot in
terms of his conception of how we human
beings we emerge is very similar to what
other thinkers like blown too else's
well we emerge from a determinism and
act and contribute something new and
then we come back into a determinism
because that we have a coherent world
that were within and then other people
do that too
bandura worriers does he happy new-year
professor will happy New Year to you as
well and to all of you
Jean Laroy I found that I can only think
about philosophical ideas when I'm
walking this may sound
silly but I was wondering if it also
happens to you that doesn't happen to me
I do have ideas that come to me while
I'm walking from place to place or while
I'm working out or will I'm doing other
things that are kind of repetitive
motions that's allowing my mind to
wander maybe that's what's going on with
you maybe maybe you need something that
allows your mind to to wander and for
you walking is what does it
it's the exclusivity part of it that for
me is it would be a little worrying if
you can only do it while you're walking
then I mean how are you gonna do it when
you're laying down or riding the bus or
you know you're sitting with a bunch of
friends over coffee or drinks or
something like that but you know I
suppose maybe it has to do with being
able to relax I don't know I don't know
your situation not to say but I mean
Aristotle the reason why it was called
the Peripatetic school is because you'd
like to walk around parapet ah pantry
pétain yeah I think right I may be
mixing my Greek up and and so he
wouldn't he would lecture as he was
walking and I I you know I kind of like
to do that myself when I have the space
so but you know just being able to think
about stuff like that when you're
walking that that could be a real
problem
cancer would I ever considered doing a
video and can lose the fall yeah sure
maybe multiple videos if I ever do get
the existentialist philosophy and
literature series where I was doing like
hour-long video started again again
which is a factor of time and stuff like
that then the fall would be a great one
to do and so it I just said it the
plague I'm do last what is my favorite
Camus novel it is the plague
all right Sarah wall do I know ken
wilber do I like that point of view ken
wilber doesn't ring a bell
well that's the American writer on
transpersonal psychology nope I I don't
know this guy at all looks like he was
roughly in my parents generation was
into a bunch of different things I don't
know the guy
[Music]
Trenton Ward I'm currently reading the
golden sayings would advice for a
self-directed learner would he share
something about that text also I was
wondering if you'd ever do a video on
Confucianism I may do videos on
Confucianism as well as other
non-western traditions of thought but
I'm always leery about doing stuff works
and thinkers and traditions where I
can't read the original you know it's
it's easy to get things wrong
and I mean I might I might end up doing
it in part because at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design
it looks like I'll be teaching a world
religions class before too long and I do
want to talk about Confucianism in terms
of virtue ethics and connected with with
business ethics as well for my business
ethics classes that I teach so I might
do some stuff now the golden sayings
you're talking about
Epictetus right the golden sayings is
just another way for the handbook or you
know whatever you want to call it people
have published the enchiridion under a
number of different titles so the same
thing goes you know for the enchiridion
I did that thing on self-directed study
of stoic philosophy you might want to
check out that video I did you know
tire course on the enchiridion that's
available out there for free
so that might be helpful as well that
just skipped again let's see what we got
here uh here's a
question from Giorgio with the Greeks
recognized our democracy as such
probably not I don't think so no they
they would see it as an incredibly
complex I mean they the ancient Greeks
would would it would take them a long
time to adjust to our current social
system and economic system once they
wrap their head around it
I think they would if they are thinking
in terms of democracy would be like wow
your democracies are really Oleg are
kacal you use this word democracy they'd
be like that guy and the the Princess
Bride
I don't think you know what this word
means so and some democracies are more
democratic in the United States we've
got some real problems with that um all
right xiangjian I guess is there a
boundary of philosophical thinking
there's lots of boundaries and every
time that we set one up we always find
ourselves on the other side of it Hegel
talks about that dynamic in the early
parts of the science of logic and I
think he's he's right about that
um when DAC is there an explanation book
of the critique of Pure Reason you'd
like a commentary you mean yeah there's
tons of them out there I don't know
whether any of them are any good because
I don't I don't read a lot of secondary
literature if I want to read a text I
just read that text I don't I don't
spend a lot of time with that sort of
thing Nick climbs Hills why do you think
ma Brosh is so underappreciated in the
history of philosophy sequence courses
at universities well he's not in French
universities because he's one of their
boys all right and they also read Pascal
way more often than English speakers do
Pascal also deserves to be read in the
you know history of modern philosophy
just as much as Spinoza does or liveness
does I think you know anglo-american
philosophy has that typical
of well there's Hobbes and we really
know what to do with him and then we've
got the Continental rationalist
Descartes Spinoza you know lie minutes
maybe we'll talk a little bit about our
know on the way and then we've got our
you know good old British and peeresses
Locke Berkeley Hume maybe we'll talk
about read a bit in the common sense
people oh we run out of time you know
that's sort of the typical way modern
philosophy but they also got a shoehorn
Rousseau in there somewhere too right
maybe won't air you know mall brush he's
an interesting guy I enjoyed reading him
I haven't read him since graduate school
but I enjoyed reading him the whole
occasional ISM thing that's pretty hard
to swallow but I don't know more hard to
swallow than Spinoza's account of things
I think right so all right so here's a
funny one a man a man ressu 56 I search
for Sandler podcast on Google and got
the naked with Catt Sadler podcast
probably want to put in Gregory Sadler
podcast
yeah Catt Sadler what is her deal I
can't remember
she came up in some some searches she
like a actress or cook or something like
then she must be trying to make some
some money on something
alright Naberius asks which branch of
moral philosophy realism objectivism
Neal ISM do you subscribe to and why I
don't know I don't subscribe to any isms
because they're always abstract you know
construe 'ls of things that mean a
million different things depending on
who's saying it you know objectivism
could mean anything you like so that I
don't find those very helpful factotum
what's your opinion on Paul Ferry Abbott
fire happened and as epistemological
anarchism
um I don't have any opinion on him I
don't really know what his position is I
can tell you this that everybody that
I've known who's really big on fire
abend has always been a jerk so that
doesn't make me want to read him all
right
bullet in cent what do I think separates
bad philosophy from good philosophy and
that a simple question or a simple
answer to that one I would say that
probably a big portion of it is whether
you actually know what you're talking
about so if you're gonna complain about
you know how Conte did this or that but
you got to know your Conte
right and if you're going to hell I'd
also say that a lot of bad philosophy is
reinventing wheels because people don't
know the history of philosophy and doing
so in ways that are less interesting
than the people who did it before Artie
Whitby if you could talk to your younger
self when you started teaching what tips
would you give your younger self wow
that's a good one don't be such a
hothead
you know when students screw up it's
it's not because they're they're being
lazy most the time or unwilling to do
things it's often just because you know
things didn't align properly so Maxwell
Thompson Kurtz how would you explain the
phenomenon of hallucinations and
schizophrenic people I don't that's not
my Harry that's all I don't worry about
that I Rebecca I always enjoy your talks
and stoicism of the Stoics I look
forward to finding your podcast happy
new year professors thanks that's very
nice I'm glad that you you like that
Floyd Mayweather senior have you ever
read Peter Rollins and his work in pyro
theology no I actually I'm following him
on patreon but I've never actually read
his stuff just because I wanted to see
what he's doing with his his account
because he seems to be pretty
successful and getting people to shell
out money for whatever whatever he's
doing but III don't have a clue what
pyro theology is supposed to be I'm
pretty distrustful of anybody who comes
up with a new you know sexy named system
or approach at this point alright I'm
going to have to scroll down a bit
because I'm gonna have to well I mean I
could hang out for a bit longer I don't
have anything I have some work I'm gonna
do today but I suppose I can go longer
than the hour I originally scheduled so
Artie Whitby what was the relationship
between Rene Descartes and the
Rosicrucians
none as far as I know but I'm not into
esoteric stuff so I don't pay any
attention to that kind of stuff
comrade Gabe what are your thoughts on
both more orthodox Marxist and post
structural Marxist conceptions of
history for example historical
materialism and also fucose concepts of
history so I think Foucault is an
interesting guy there's a lot of good
work out there that adapts Foucault not
so much in philosophy or in like
sociology and history and other things
like that I mean I think that that Marx
had his finger on a number of points
where he was right and it's great that
Marx is part of a classical tradition I
mean if you read Marx and you actually
pay attention you don't approach it in a
polemical you know sort of like or you
get a bad guy or or the O's the Saviour
kind of kind of [ __ ] stuff but you
actually like just see what's going on
there there's a lot of stuff in Marx
that's very Aristotelian you know that's
why you know within like the Alistair
McIntyre oriented spectrum there's
there's you know Aristotelian Thomas and
hardcore Marxist and they come together
and talk about things there's you know
radical Aristotelian ISM so I think that
you know Marxism itself is you know
there's a constant attention to
which needs to be there whether it's
Marxism or whether it's you know other
other you know things like say Catholic
social theory there always has to be
attention to how are the people who are
vulnerable being affected by things and
who actually has power you know and how
do we move towards the good the good
that we would share together and and is
history moving towards more and more
Oleg our kacal and and you know very
stratified positions or can we move it
towards something that's more
egalitarian those are all key questions
that the Marxist tradition helps to keep
alive when it's doing its job there's
plenty of you knows we used to call them
Eamon Marxist out there rich kids who
you know read some Marx and now they're
gonna you know fix the world or some
nonsense like that but they're actually
not going to open up their pocketbooks
let alone get into you know real work to
do that I'm not a Marxist myself but I
think there's a lot to be recommended in
reading Marx and Marxist successors
potting soil full seminar on boomers
please that might infuriate me it's
funny actually so my kid Madi remarks to
my dad who's obviously a Boomer right my
biological dad he he said you're one of
the good ones
the boomers really messed a lot of
thickness stuff this is a twelve year
old right a member of Generation Z said
you're one of the good boomers all the
rest of them are bad now that's typical
kids rightly they have a fairly
simplistic understanding of the world
all right let's see here some people
arguing back and forth about marks oh
there's mark Trumbull longtime
correspondent
guy who had met up with his his wife at
stoic on and then here at the
Aristotelian conference somebody I'd
call a long-standing friend Happy New
Year may you have health an insight in
the following year thanks mark that's
that's really good and I hope the same
for you and your wife and I hope our
paths cross again
you know weather down here and in the
Milwaukee area if I ever get up near
Toronto again we'll definitely have to
get together and and hang out and
hopefully have a meal together this time
that would that be nice all four of us
so all right Jacob Donato the stories
were telling ourselves are lies covering
up what we're doing the truth is what
we're doing in social interaction not
the inner stories dr. G Jack this is an
example of meta Phil oh I guess there's
no follow-up to that okay Steven Warren
Happy New Year's Eve Happy New Year's to
you do you have any thoughts on
heidegger's being towards death yeah I
think it's a good insight I you know I
mean I know that myself I since I've
been a kid and I know other people like
this as well including a long-standing
correspondent to my name Bruce from
childhood we had that that effectivity
where we knew that that we could die
right people say all children they
believe they're you know invincible I
never thought that you know and I think
there's there's others like that as well
and and don't know that we can
generalize it to say that it's an
absolute condition of all design you
know all human existence maybe there are
some people who just just never do
encounter that but they're missing
something by not doing so I think
Heidegger is also right that most people
do try to cover this up in some way or
another not not consciously but you know
they there's a reaction against it the
contingency of our existence I don't
think that's unique to him I mean I
think Nietzsche was on to the same thing
and I think Kierkegaard talks about
something quite similar
so I think there's something there
Christos says he's interested in reading
Kierkegaard which of his works would I
suggest I you start off with that's a
good question
usually I start people on that short
selection the crowd is on truth and the
present age which are pretty good for
introducing people to Kierkegaard I
often teach fear and trembling
philosophical fragments could actually
be a good place to start as well or
sickness on unto death you know that's
nice and short it's dense but it's
pretty good so I mean again with
philosophers expect to read and reread
and reread so you know it doesn't you
know you don't have to actually start
necessarily flood from nowhere do you
have any advice besides getting
professional help for someone struggling
with suicidal thoughts I mean what I
have to say may not be particularly
helpful also this you're definitely not
alone and there's you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of people who are
struggling in that way I certainly have
struggled in my lifetime at different
points and so I don't know if that helps
to know that you know sometimes hearing
that other people have struggled with it
is you know helpful sometimes it's not
another thing to realize is that however
shitty you feel and if you do have
suicidal thoughts you know it's usually
because you're feeling pretty pretty bad
it is possible to not feel as bad and to
do that without you know resorting to
chemicals but but to to do so by
working on yourself it won't happen
immediately there's no like magic bullet
that you can snap your fingers and
suddenly you feel better but it you know
there are things out there that can help
and so if you have you know what William
James called faith in others faith right
belief and others belief you don't
necessarily have to believe it right now
but you you can you can trust that other
people are right in saying that there
are things that could help you over time
and I'm sorry that your your if you if
it that's you that's struggling with it
I'm sorry that you're struggling with it
this is a particularly hard time to
write the holidays so that's that's
something important to keep in mind as
well sometimes things look worse in
these these weird days at the end of the
year and the darkest time of the year as
well so I don't know if that helps at
all but at least I took a stab at it I
guess
Anthony Vickery how would I compare
Pascal's religious thought with that of
Kierkegaard they've got a lot of things
in common you know
both of them often get tired as being
anti rationalist but they're really
saying no rationality it's gonna be
truly rational has to be able to engage
with what goes beyond it what it's other
is and they're both you know drawing on
the history of Christian thought and
religious experience so you know one
from a Lutheran perspective one from a
Catholic perspective although Pascal's
you know effectively a Jansenist so kind
of a Protestant perspective there as
well three by four architecture what's
the best question I've been asked on a
live chat I don't know that's that's a
great quiet done so Nicolas asked when I
can't really answer what philosophical
papers or works were most influential
this decade
I don't know you know I I don't keep my
finger on that pulse so I can't really
say uh here's a good one kuma throws
what's your take on thought experiments
I think that can be quite helpful I
think that making a career out of
playing around with like trolley
problems is is not a it's not much of a
philosophical career but I think thought
experiments can be quite quite good for
driving things home I mean we often see
that being done in fiction don't we one
of the oldest thought experiments is the
plato's ring of guy gee so and I use
that almost every semester with with
some some class right so they can be
quite good David Ireland studying for
LSAT and it's why phone my lecture is
any advice for LSAT student studying
logic I don't know I don't know that
much about the LSAT I would say do as
many logic puzzles as you can the way
you get good at doing logic is by doing
it you know doing doing exercise after
exercise after exercise I'm philosophy
and science what are your thoughts on
Robert Wallace's books Hegel's
philosophy and reality freedom and god I
haven't read it so I don't know Zeno
asked him I read phenomenology of
perception if so can I offer any advice
on how to read it yeah as a matter of
fact I I took an entire course on the
phenomenology of perception and when I
was in grad school and I like Marilyn
see quite a bit it's it's useful to know
a bit about who Cyril and maybe even
Schaller a bit yet when you're heading
into it but it's kind of funny so part
of the backstory that book is before who
Cyril stuff was actually translated into
French people assume that maralell Ponte
and what he was putting forward in the
phenomenology of perception was like
very close to the Cyril as it turned out
no it's he's doing his own thing that's
influenced quite a bit by his role but
he's really doing his own
and so you know he fears off in a lot of
different directions but one of the
things here's something to keep in mind
that'll really help out and he says this
early on the book all the different
fields that he's studying like language
or sexuality or you know motor things
they all come together in normal
perception it's when people are are
damaged in some way these things start
getting split off from each other not
functioning well with each other so that
might be helpful
Jakub rush what's my viewpoint on the
Epicurean response to death I always
found it to be a rational sublime
towards death anxiety so what is the
Epicurean response to death it's this
kind of interesting little argument that
says you don't have to worry about death
why not
because you know it's you're not going
to be there when you're dead there's
nothing that you're going to suffer from
and you know that's that's not not bad
it's certainly better than Socrates
argument made in the apology where he
says it's going to be like a really
great sleep having don't you remember
the most wonderful sleep that you had
you know it'll be like that and then he
said well yeah but you got to be
conscious in order to actually enjoy
that that sleep so Epicurus is saying
there's no consciousness after after
death interestingly Epicurious left a
will and you know I did I did a podcast
episode with the death hangout guys
specifically on Philosopher's wills and
we talked about Epicurus and well why
would a materialist leave a will you
know why should he care about what
happens afterwards so it's kind of an
interesting issue fled from nowhere
death cafe could be an anime show well I
think they got the trademark on it
the death cafe people so I don't know oh
yeah there's a great suggestion here
from William Thomas Sherman the question
about death before tried Tolstoy his
death of even Ilic although you know
that one's kind of depressing
so all right mark says surely aunts
telling me to tell you Happy New Year to
you Andy Andy well happy New Year to you
and truly an from both of us and I hope
someday we're able to meet up again
that'll be very nice
Raymond thoughts on philosophy of Ridley
Scott I don't know that does Ridley
Scott have a philosophy he certainly got
an aesthetic but I don't know if he's
got a philosophy
Bruno asks what are some of the benefits
you attained from studying philosophy
that you that you might enjoy as well
well I like the fact that that I have a
number of different concepts that have
helped me to live my life in a better
way and to slowly progressively unscrew
it up not not finished yet and things
keep getting screwed up but philosophy
at least the the philosophy that I've
been studying and the ways in which I've
been studying it have been very helpful
for that so I think that could be quite
good Steve asks I've taken a few
philosophy classes but I haven't noticed
many people talking about the pragmatist
is there a reason for this as pragmatism
not very popular
well that's because analytic philosophy
when it came into the United States it
effectively colonized it and it really
ended up repressing a number of other
ways of doing philosophy which included
classical American philosophy which
included the pragmatic tradition it
included you know what we nowadays call
continental philosophy which is being
done large it made its way largely
through Catholic universities in part
because Catholics were in touch with
what was going on in Europe at the time
it requests other modes of doing
philosophy often deliberate
I mean I saw this where I went to
graduate school Southern Illinois
University there was a period where the
analytics who were dominating the
department tried to phase out all the
continental and American philosophy
people so that that that's part of the
reason why and then you know you most
people in academic philosophy or rather
conservative in this respect they may be
politically liberal but they're
conservative in that they think that
what they studied is what's important so
if they didn't get a very broad spectrum
of you know research they're mostly
exposed to analytic philosophy they they
don't do the work of like looking
outside of that and and you know the
work that's required to like appreciate
other traditions well then they think
and a lot analytic philosophy is the
only game in town or that continental
and analytic philosophy or the only
games in town and they forget about all
these other ways of doing philosophy
including good history of philosophy so
yeah that's that's part of it
Pablo says I wanted to thank you for
your work on YouTube if our Hegel is
just amazing thanks very much I'm hoping
I can get to get it back going this this
coming year I was gonna try to shoot a
video tonight but I probably am not
going to let's see here X bluebells how
long before AI gets legal personhood
status well that is a really interesting
question
I think it'll happen piecemeal and of
course it'll happen in in you know like
one country before it happens in another
country I don't know
and and I think one of the more
interesting questions to ask is what
kind of AI what function of a I will get
personhood status will it be a robot
that moves around and does things will
it be you know an autonomous car will it
be some
of AI that does a fairly routine task
that replaces a human being that's a
good question right honey rod says I'd
like to take this opportunity to thank
and appreciate the work you do on
YouTube thank you very much it's that
that's that's quite nice Alexander
didn't need to really think that
philosophers were diseased or unwell
people he thought that that they they
were and they weren't I mean he thinks
also that the category of the priests in
the genealogy of morals is effectively
disease but brings about something new
as a result so it's not simply a
reductionist sort of view but nature
really does think that that human beings
as we're doing our thinking and
philosophies and mode of thinking we are
motivated by the stuff that we're you
know fundamentally interested in you
know so yeah alright just skipped a bit
let's see what we got here yeah there's
a lot of there I think there's quite a
few questions that I won't get to even
if I try all right um Reinhard Moyer who
would you say are the greatest Christian
philosophers well definitely Kierkegaard
hecht I mean Thomas Aquinas is certainly
quite quite good and I you know I'm a
big fan of ants um I don't know it
depends on what we want them for doesn't
it I mean Pascal - you shouldn't should
never skip Pascal
interestingly Paul Griffiths when I when
I was interviewing for a position at
University of Illinois in Chicago used
one of the people who was interviewing
me and he took me to his introduction to
Catholicism class they only had three
books Augustine's Confessions parts of
Thomas Aquinas is Summa theologia and
Pascal's Ponce's really nice
representation there right so that's
that's kind of good-x bluebells have I
ever thought about writing a book that
weave together a moral philosophy that
could serve us well in our current times
I'm stuck in stoicism but don't know how
to mix the other stuff in well with that
last part I would take a look at
Alistair McIntyre and what he has to say
and I would also take a look at Long's
article if you just type in you know a
long stoicism McIntyre the article will
come up I forget the exact name of it
but he talks about how stoicism can be
this living tradition but if I ever
thought about writing a book that we
have together a moral philosophy yes I
have I don't know whether I can actually
do it it's one thing to daydream about
writing a book it's another to actually
pull it off I don't know that I could
actually do anything that would be
better than what other people are doing
out there so I'm certainly gonna like do
things that are better pieces of that as
a matter of fact I'll put this idea out
there I've thought about writing
something that would be sort of like
real cos letters to a young poet you
know sort of like letters to a young
philosopher about how you might start
studying philosophy and what what things
to avoid and what things to definitely
get into and and you know but that's not
so much about moral philosophy that's
more like how do you how do you study
philosophy so all right Alexandre I find
myself being less enthused with modern
philosophies days and more interest in
Christianity thoughts well there's a lot
of overlap between them right
mean Descartes is a Christian
philosopher according to himself he
calls the meditations Christian
philosophy and the dedication of the
Sorbonne and there there's others who
are actually probably more real
Christians like pus com
I'm character garroted people like that
that we mentioned already you know
you're gonna I think over the course of
your studies you're gonna find you're
more interested in some things and at
one point in time and then you get less
interested in it something else comes in
there I mean I thought at one time I
just wanted to only do philosophy of
language and then I got led into other
things by you know actually learning
Greek for example so it that's okay just
you know don't don't don't like abandon
the stuff that you you had think of it
as you know you're acquiring more and
more interesting things Floyd has a
clarification here I wouldn't mind the
label pyro theology too much he's
influenced by Hegel Lacan like jejak and
ultimately likes to help others to
recognize the big other anything and
including Christianity okay that sounds
interesting maybe I'll give it a look
you know depending on how much time I
have one of these days I mean I kind of
would just rather read the straight look
on myself so yeah polygraph polygraph Oh
Mitch what do you think about
personality development trainings and
reading motivating literature what do
you think about Dale Carnegie like books
I think those are at a low level they're
quite useful but then you need something
that's actually more robust Donald
Robertson actually had a great
observation that he made one time so
Donald Robertson major figure in the
modern stoic movement right also a CBT
practitioner and he said you know CBT
works for some people for some things
it's a great modality of therapy it's
got a lot in connection
ancient stoic philosophy but nobody ever
reads Burns's feeling good
more than once if they have to it's not
like Marcus Aurelius where people go
back and reread the meditations over and
over and over again so so what's what's
going on there well there's something
more something substantive that's not
there in the CBT as a way of doing
things
and I think you can say the same thing
about Dale Carnegie
I remember reading when I was a kid how
to make friends and influence people and
being like okay I see what this guy's up
to I don't know why people pay him for
this [ __ ] because half of this stuff you
can kind of figure out on your own and I
guess they just need somebody to tell
them this this sort of thing so you know
I I think they're they're not bad in
themselves but I think that you want you
want something more than that hang over
here is where there's so many different
interpretations of the word dialectic
for instance the instance the
differences between Plato's constant and
Hegel's usage because they're different
philosophers and doing different things
with it and the dialectic you know like
with Hegel it's something historical
with with Plato it's a it's a way of
understanding reality itself with Conte
it's something bad to engage in it leads
you away from the truth
you know most philosophical terms are
multi meaning right they're what we call
polysemic or equivocal so you know
mister meow
what's my IQ so the last time I he was
measured I think I was in like maybe
seventh grade or so on it was like 139
so not not you know anywhere near genius
level I'll say this my IQ is high enough
whatever it happens to be that I think
that IQ is mostly [ __ ] and that
anybody who places stock in it as a
measure of anything is really kind of
silly
I mean we know that that it's not a
great predictor of how well people are
going to do with things and it changes
over time and you know you could have
the same person test several times and
get very different answers so alright we
got about three more minutes before I
gotta go and start doing some stuff
let's see what we got that I can grab on
to quick Jeff Burroughs is that a Black
Sabbath t-shirt it certainly is I got
another one of my acquisitions I've got
about ten different band t-shirts that I
wear oftentimes to work out let's see
here
black what any advice for a recent
college dropout ya realize that that
dropping out of college doesn't have to
define you even if other people want it
to when that there's many many different
ways to be healthy and have good
relationships and and develop a career
that you'll actually find meaning in and
enjoy to be successful right there's a
lot of different ways to do that many
people dropped out of college one one of
my my good close friends did so when he
was 19 and he has a computer company
that he's run for many many years he's a
you know job creator he's got like 15
people working for him and now he
doesn't he doesn't even manage that
company and now he does work with
artificial intelligence and various
types of trading and he's very
interested in that that sort of thing
and he dropped out of college I'm pretty
sure if I had gone into college having
not been in the army I probably would
have dropped out myself so so I you know
don't don't allow it to define you you
could say
let's see what else we got here a lot of
back-and-forth about Jordan Peterson
people are talking about mobile Tiger
home could I do a video on how Disney
ruined the eastern philosophy and Star
Wars and replaced it with essentially
Vudu without consequences well I'm gonna
probably take some people off here first
of all I don't really do pop culture
stuff because there's plenty of other
people doing that sort of thing I've
always thought the Star Wars Jedi thing
was super super hokey you know it's so
wishy-washy you know sort of lowest
common denominator all the things that
that I've disliked about people claiming
what they were doing was Zen or Eastern
mysticism when I think they were full of
[ __ ] I think applies to the Jedi's so I
don't think that Disney could make it
worse than it already was and when I
went back and rewatched the original
Star Wars trilogy because I saw that you
know the prequels and I was like the
first one I've been watching this is
really terrible you know I said well
maybe they'll get better
and they didn't and then I went back
with my kids and watched the original
ones I was like holy crap is Luke a
whiny kid you know and this isn't good
writing you know I I just don't I don't
get much out of the Star Wars thing
myself
unfortunately so I'm not somebody to do
that for you I think all right Nicks
so you like maiden I certainly do as a
matter of fact iron maiden used to be my
favorite band I can't really name a
favorite band at this time but iron
maiden would definitely be in the top
five you know as would Black Sabbath but
not just Ossie Black Sabbath gotta
remember dia was with them really
revitalized the band and then Ian Gillan
sang with them Tony Martin you know
Glenn Hughes seven stars a pretty good
album so there's there's a lot of really
great singers that have been with them
Motorhead of course Judas Priest
well then who would I include is you
know like my fifth probably kiss
you know so all right I'm gonna go out
on that so I stayed over about half an
hour longer than I was going to hope all
of you have a great New Year's I got a
lot of you know video content to shoot
and so I'll see all of you in the
interwebs at one point or another if
you're in this area that is the Greater
Milwaukee area which would include you
know Chicagoland or the Fox cities or
going west to Madison you might consider
coming to one of our face-to-face events
that we're going to be having you can
find those on the reason io calendars I
get them put in there or going to my
Facebook page but I hope all of you have
a great New Year's you know whether you
make resolutions or not you know keep in
mind too if you're feeling blue that
you're not alone in that and that that
there are there's no guarantee that
things will get better but there's ways
to try to make them so so alright I'll
see all of you somewhere down the line